les immeubles neufs seront ils adaptés
un jour aux personnes handicapées
physiques
ils sont plusieurs centaines de milliers
qui paralysait assis dans un fauteuil
roulant non pour univers que leur
chambre
[Musique]
gilles à 24 ans il n'est pas sorti de
chez lui depuis six ans victime d'un
appartement inadaptée et de
l'inaccessibilité de son appartement
[Musique]
quel est votre vie depuis six ans
et bien qu'on finit dans ma chambre
chambre salle à manger pour changer de
temps en temps et puis pas ressasser
tout où certaines consultations que je
fais à l'hôpital de garches tous les
trimestre où les six mois cela dépend
d'eux les convocations quels sont les
reproches majeurs que vous faites à cet
appartement
il reproche tout ça mais ce sont ainsi
quand même un immeuble qui à 35 ans donc
il ya 35 ans s'inquiète pas ces
problèmes là il le principal reproche
que les portes on la rigueur je dois
encore passer mais elle se connaît pas
si large le couloir je ne veux pas
habitués à accéder et les chambres et
des pièces ne sont pas assez larges les
meubles dedans je ne peux pas du tout
circuit avec mon fauteuil et je ne peux
pas du tout dessin le moment ne peux pas
me descendre ha seule elle ne pas
risquer de me descendre
et puis je ne peux quand même pas
demander voisin de prince maurice les
logements les immeubles en particulier
surtout ne sont pas du tout accessible
un handicapé par là évidemment certains
sont de plain-pied si haut ce qui est
assez rare et quand ils ne sont pas il
n'y a pas du tout de rampes
d'accessibilité
immeuble
voire même au 6e poste mairie
centre de sécurité sociale
et bien d'autres au jour au cinéma voir
même c'est un grand problème parce que
je n'ai
aucun aucun handicapé une plaque y
accéder mais pour vous comment
envisagez-vous un un appartement dans
lequel vous vous sentiriez à l'aise
et bien il faudrait alors justement
l'accessibilité
soit de plain pied ou avec
plan incliné
et puis l'intérieur et bien
les
des sanitaires assez vaste et surtout
encore une fois les couloirs les
couloirs assez large
aucun fauteuil roulant de tétraplégie
qui fait 1 m 35
d'envergure si on peut dire je puisse
tourner à l'intérieur
j'ai demandé à gilles son idée sur
l'intégration des handicapés à la
société
[Musique]
au lieu de groupe et
ses handicaps et pourquoi ne pas les
répartir dans l'ensemble d'un groupe
les mélanger avec les valides
ce qui serait source le plan moral
beaucoup plus intéressant parce que j'ai
quittée par exemple je prends mon cas
même j'ai bien d'autres quittent
l'hôpital pour s'éloigner de cet univers
et que fait
la société elle nous remet dans un
ensemble d'handicapés sa non il ne le
faut pas au point de vue moral physique
est tous avec vous avez pensé qu'un jour
vous pourriez être seul oui
et alors sans rien dire mais je dépense
alors
j'en sais rien
mais j'y pense le moins possible
nous sommes peu nombreux qui prenons
conscience de leurs problèmes tous les
jours immeubles neufs centre de sécurité
sociale banque hôtel des postes ou de
police cinéma se construisent les
handicapés physiques n'y ont pas accès
la société les en exclu toute une
journée nous avons suivi dans paris un
jeune handicapé
voyez les obstacles auxquels ils se
heurtent
[Musique]
une
un autre témoignage celui d'elisabeth
une étudiante de 29 ans paralysée depuis
11 ans sans compter les années d'hôpital
quelles sont vos activités
au début de mon handicap je me suis
refusé catégoriquement reprendre mes
études
malgré les encouragements des
professeurs de médecine de garges tout
simplement parce que je pensais que est
en fauteuil roulant je n'avais plus
besoin de travailler et que je ne
pourrai surtout pas avoir une place dans
la société
au bout de ces quatre ans passés entre
quatre murs où j'ai beaucoup lu certes
on était très très choyé par une pas des
parents très aisément une famille très
nombreuse
j'ai réagi quand même à l'âge de 21 ans
22 ans en disant il faut quand même que
tu
trouves une indépendance puisque quand
des parents ne seront plus là tu vas te
retrouver seul
est ce que vous sentez encore
dépendantes
moralement
non
puisque justement j'ai réagi et pour moi
c'était en tout le pauvre indépendante
et une plastique lesté de les études
essentiellement qu'ils allaient me
sauver
de ma dépendance
mais dépendante physiquement bien
entendu d'une infirmière tous les matins
qui viennent donc là j'ai besoin d'elle
pour refaire ma toilette tout m'habiller
pour me lever
ensuite comparé les repas sont des buts
que l'on prend et ça rentre un peu près
de la routine quotidienne
on n'y pense plus mais ce que tous les
jours vous fait penser à votre handicap
si je malaxe habilité
je vois actuellement
les études que je poursuis au panthéon
eh bien je dis franchement
au moins de deux mois après avec mons
mes coups j'ai voulu abandonner
j'ai dit non tant pis le doctorat en
droit n'est pas pour toi tu te comptera
d'une licence en droit mais tu vois bien
que passe un doctorat en droit au
panthéon ou à la sorbonne ce qui revient
au même tu est interdite pourquoi parce
qu'il ya ce problème
d'escalier et donc d'inaccessibilité les
architectes devraient penser un peu plus
souvent qu'il existe malheureusement en
france des centaines de milliers de
petits fauteuils roulants ils doivent
vivre
sortir travailler et pour cela avoir un
logement
approprié c'est très bien parfois nous
voyons des rampes d'accès
dans les
temps des immeubles qu'on a le mieux
mais il n'y a pas d'ascenseur on a pensé
à la rampe d'accès mais l'ascenseur a
été oublié
elisabeth quels sont vos loisirs
ils sont assez restreints
je dois l'avouer
parce que je suis étudiante et que le
travail que l'on demandé est assez
important mais quand même je pense
sortir et puisque j'aime beaucoup la vie
j'aime beaucoup la vie comme j'ai
toujours aimé avant mon accident et
j'aime beaucoup aller au cinéma
au restaurant avec des amis est
malheureusement toujours ce problème
d'accessibilité les cinémas je crois que
je n'ai vu que deux films de pub ici à
paris pourquoi est ce que les bons films
étaient mettez une excessive
[Musique]